[Music]
president obama is traveling the country
did you know this and he spent last
night in las vegas
okay this morning he woke up on his
hotel room floor trying to figure out
what to do about a tiger a baby and nine
percent unemployment
problem
uh mitt romney of course in the news
according to new polls it just came out
mitt romney does very well with
republican voters who make more than 200
thousand dollars
yeah
or as romney calls them trailer trash
can someone live on that
how do you do it
they must eat garbage
that's nothing like how romney sounds
but i'm going with that impression from
now i like the evil romney better than
them
there's robot
that's no good either uh in a in an
interview listen to this rapper ice t
called secretary of state hillary
clinton a g meaning gangster
yeah
no ice says he likes clinton's policy of
broad consensus on international
problems
before hoes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anyone watch toddlers and tiaras here
[Applause]
you should go i know
i'm seriously each going yeah yeah
tv is a gift and you're wasting it yeah
no uh one of the moms from toddlers and
tiaras is suing media outlets claiming
they tried to sexualize her daughter
yeah yeah the mom said they turned an
innocent pole dance by a three-year-old
into something dirty
[Applause]
a florida man was recently arrested for
taking upskirt shots at walmart
yeah it will it will come to trial as
soon as they can find 12 jurors willing
to look at upskirt shots
of walmart shoppers
[Music]
romney's like what is this walmart
it's not even a place
see i'm putting them together and that's
what makes it beautiful
you're going to like this
a
no i don't know i think you will a new
study
shows that when that's very interesting
shows that when men perform oral sex on
women
it can cause them to contract mouth
cancer later in life
yeah
the study also says that according to
women most american men have nothing to
worry about
[Applause]
taco bell in the news taco bell
what a nice
transition i'm gonna get out there
goodbye everybody
[Applause]
i think i went from that joke right to
taco
taco bell has introduced a new breakfast
menu
yeah
yeah taco bell says it's a good idea
because breakfast is the most important
bowel explosion of the day
[Music]
i'm proud of what i do for a living